bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
avec quelqu'un qui n'est d'ailleurs
bonjour une semaine marquée par le doute
doute au sommet de l'état un président
de la république au plus bas dans les
sondages sifflé sur les champs elysées
en innovant et un parlementaire de la
majorité qui appelle à la démission du
premier ministre semaine très difficile
pour l'exécutif le doute aussi dans la
rue la fronde contre les rythmes
scolaires s'amplifie après les
formateurs les employés municipaux et
les parents d'élèves les professeurs
d'école manifestent à leur tour pour
dénoncer la réforme et puis le plus de
lait d'eau sur fond de doutes encore une
fois c'est le titre d'un film qui sort
sur les écrans cette semaine le film
raconte l'histoire de la gauche de 2006
à 2012 à travers deux couples on en
parle deuxième partie de cette émission
est notre invité cette semaine jean
christophe cambadélis bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous député socialiste
de paris secrétaire national du ps en
charge de l'europe et de l'international
et vice président du pse heures sur
votre blog vous avez publié plusieurs
petites petit article au vitriol
j'enrage de voir la gauche larmes au
pied face aux remises en cause de la
république ecrivez-vous notamment est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vu le contexte et le
climat qui règne dans la majorité vous
seriez encore candidat au poste de
premier secrétaire du ps
c'est pas le sujet du jour honnêtement l
indicateur vous aimez je pense que c'est
ce n'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il faut c'est que les socialistes se
réveillent il faut que la gauche
non seulement résiste mais partent au
combat parce que nous sommes dans une
situation où nous avons été un peu un
peu naïf nous avons cru que l'alternance
allait de soi et il y à une partie de la
droite et de l'extrême droite qui estime
que la gauche n'est pas légitime au
pouvoir qu'elle juge à l'alternative il
y a aussi des mécontentements 1 je ne
dirais pas des doutes je dirais des
mécontentements
mais il y a aussi cette cristallisation
qu'il faut avoir en tête ce qui s'est
passé le 11 novembre et est de ce
registre là justement mardi les
incidents du rangement montrent une
répercussion bien entendu à l'assemblée
nationale
françois hollande hué par des militants
d'extrême droite et par les bonnets
rouges après les incidents survenus le
11 novembre à paris réaction unanime à
gauche comme à droite sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale à quelques
exceptions près ont fait front pour
défendre les valeurs de la république
elisa bartholomé
un député agressé blessé de plusieurs
coups de couteau françois hollande hué
par des sympathisants d'extrême droite
lors des questions au gouvernement
les commémorations du 11 novembre était
au coeur des débats sur un sujet d'une
telle gravité gauche comme droite se
montrent unis et condamne les
débordements je demande que notre
assemblée condamne de manière unanime
cette tragédie il ne faut ni oublié ni
banaliser ce qui est constitutif d'un
crime contre des élus et donc contre la
république quand le 11 novembre
on vise le président de la république
c'est la république que l'on vise et moi
je n'accepte pas qu'on porte atteinte à
la république
condamnation unanime sur chaque bancs de
l'assemblée pendant presque toute la
séance mais quelques minutes avant 16
heures la politique reprend le dessus
vous avez récolté ce qui a été semé et
c'est la france sa mémoire qui a été
offensé après avoir conspué le président
sarkozy vilipendée cas critiques
acquitté
si les gosses la liberté d'expression
sifflé sur les bancs de la gauche et
c'est le ministre de l'intérieur qui
monte au créneau j'ai entendu votre
première phrase
est votre première phrase madame boyer
non seulement elle est contradictoire
totalement avec ce que beaucoup de vos
collègues ont exprimé ces erreurs
avaient ce que jean françois copé a dit
un instant
mais les particulièrement dangereuse le
premier ministre a prévenu la justice
sera ferme face aux atteintes à l'ordre
public et à la république jean
christophe cambadélis vous me disiez à
l'instant pas des doutes mais une forme
d'inquiétude vous n'avez pas
l'impression qu'on assiste à une forme
de désacralisation de la parole
présidentielle
est-ce que j'ai pas l'impression que la
parole s'est libérée ces derniers temps
mais vous savez la parole s'est libérée
depuis longtemps
n'oublie c'est normal mais je veux dire
dans les années 70 la parole
présidentielle et est souvent remise en
cause et est critique et il y avait des
journaux satiriques il
attendait parce que les médias ont
explosé parce que je pas dit c'est pain
sert technique à partir du moment où
vous avez les informations 24 heures sur
24 et vous faut bien fournir les
informations ou celles ci sont souvent
en boucle eh bien vous avez une
situation quasiment de concurrence
médiatique et donc partir de là
mécaniquement eh bien on fait que le
présent la république s'exprime samedi à
14 heures ou à 13 heures et on donne la
parole je ne dis pas que c'est la faute
je dis que c'est mécanique et donc après
on s'étonne mais non c'est comme ça il
faut avoir il faut apprendre à vivre
dans son temps où la parole politique
est immédiatement contesté sur twitter
sur facebook sur le net dans les médias
la politique donc il faut continuer son
chemin et dire ce qu'on estime être
juste parce que ça va tellement vite que
l'on a le temps de faire le tour du
cadran et pour revenir à la position qui
est énoncé en résidence tiens
il m'a assez délétère une contestation
de fonds climat de désobéissance à la
fois civils et civiques pour vous qu'est
ce qui explique sa quelles sont les
raisons de fond ce que vous comprenez la
pluralité de facteurs liés à une
pluralité de facteurs il ya des facteurs
objectifs qui sait le redressement de la
france et quand on doit redresser la
france en serrant les dépenses publiques
et en se trouvant devant des déficits
publics qui sont colossaux évidemment ça
ne peut pas satisfaire
l'ensemble des français nous sommes dans
une phase de désintoxication de la
dépense publique évidemment il ya des
tensions et puis il ya des problèmes
beaucoup plus pour y est beaucoup plus
important il ya les problèmes auxquels
sont confrontés les français en terme
d'identité en termes de république en
termes de mondialisation etc tout ça
matures en même temps la tension touche
aussi la majorité c'est décidément un
début de semaine sous haute tension
puisqu'un parlementaires de la majorité
à laissé entendre qu'un changement de
premier ministre serait bienvenue pas de
quoi troubler jean marc ayrault qui
reçoit immédiatement du soutien sujet
signé yoan la
pire que les sifflets la remise en cause
venue d'un parlementaire de la majorité
dans les colonnes du parisien malek
boutih vient de demander la démission du
premier ministre
à l'entrée de la réunion du groupe ps le
député de l'essonne assumer enfonce le
clou le remaniement c'est maintenant
fait prévu dans les institutions c'est
une pratique politique usuelles j'ai
rien dit d'extraordinaire tous les
gouvernements tous les tous les
gouvernements confrontés à des
difficultés envisage cette situation je
vais poser publiquement c'est là mais là
maintenant il va y avoir débat au sein
du groupe vous allez aux juifs ou pas
pas obligatoirement j'en sais rien c'est
pas j'ai pas un tel poids chez
simplement exprimer quelque chose que
d'autres dix ans avec loire s'il clame
ne pas être le seul à le penser il sera
bel et bien le seul à le dire alors
qu'une nouvelle fois des manifestations
mettant gravement en cause l'autorité de
l'état viennent d'avoir lieu malek
boutih a perdu une occasion de se taire
estiment la plupart de ses camarades
donc je dis aux copains maintenant
qu'est une étiquette socialiste connaît
sur dos qu'il faut qu'ils aillent au
charbon et qu'ils aillent au boulot dès
fois de la politique du gouvernement il
ya un pas qu'on ne peut pas franchir et
donc tirer dans le dos de ses propres
amis ça n'est certainement pas être
responsable et puisqu'il est une
nouvelle fois question de son autorité à
jean marc ayrault d'enfer lui même la
démonstration face à la presse en ce qui
me concerne j'ai une tâche difficile à
accomplir
rien ne m'impressionnent et je n'ai
aucun doute sur le soutien des
parlementaires socialistes députés et
sénateurs donc de soutien de toute la
majorité puis dans l'hémicycle en
réponse au président du groupe ump votre
majorité étale ses divisions matin midi
et soir elle n'est tenue en rien
monsieur le premier ministre
l'horizon de la france ne peut pas se
limiter au nombre de jours où vous
resterez à matignon vous êtes en train
de faire croire qu'il ya une crise
institutionnelle
mais de quoi parlez vous monsieur jacob
remettez vous en cause la légitimité du
suffrage universel et que je sache
françois hollande est élu pour cinq ans
président de la république alors si vous
voulez le contester aller avec ce qui
m'arrive est un simple le 11 novembre
sur les champs elysées
face à l'opposition qui demandent que le
premier ministre se soumettent à la
question de confiance à charge pour la
majorité de données dans l'hémicycle et
ailleurs des gages de solidarité à un
chef de gouvernement qui en a bien
besoin alors que se passe-t-il au sommet
de l'état combien de temps le couple
exécutif peut-il tenir c'est le zoom de
l'est de
notre chroniqueur roland cayrol est avec
nous bonjour roland bonjour alors tué
lors des cérémonies du 11-novembre des
records d'impopularité
combien de temps cela peut-il tenir je
crois que le premier ministre a rappelé
que le président est élu pour cinq ans
et
il n'y a pas de sortie
institutionnelle d'une crise politique
comme celle-là il va pas dissoudre il
prendrait une défaite énorme dans la
figure elle va pas faire un référendum
ça serait n'ont évidemment pas
démissionné la seule solution que le
président de la république c'est de
faire le gros dos de penser que sa
politique finira par donner des
résultats et qu'il se verront et
d'attendre l'échec inévitable des
élections municipales et présidentielles
le redressement c'est pas pour
aujourd'hui le redressement c'est pour
dans quelques mois si c'est possible
s'il ya des résultats économiques
alors
techniquement
le président de la république est là
pour cinq ans la majorité a été élu on
entend il a dans la droite des voix qui
remettent en cause la légitimité de du
pouvoir je pense qu'ils ont tort et qui
prennent position contre les
institutions mais on peut prendre des
initiatives politiques il n'est pas
c'est pas un thème c'est pas interdit
d'abord est d'abord si vous me laissez
30 secondes je vous réponds
d'abord il ya des initiatives à prendre
sur le terrain de la défense de la
république on voit partout des hommes et
des femmes socialistes ou autres de
gauche qui ne supporte pas le climat tel
qu'il est développé aujourd'hui que ce
soit par rapport à madame taubira aux
barbares aux sifflets les présidences
des retours présidentielle par exemple
moi je parle du parti socialiste un
canton le président de la république en
son temps il sera amené à faire le point
de la situation d'abord sur l'inversion
de la courbe du chômage si ça a lieu
aussi ça n'a pas lieu il sera amené à
prendre des initiatives
à mon avis au niveau de l'europe car on
s'aperçoit que
les la situation est mûre pour la
réorientation de la construction
européenne avec les déclarations de
bruxelles sur les excédents
l'allemagne à ce niveau-là
d'impopularité roland cayrol est-ce
qu'il est encore possible d'être entendu
d'être
je crois que le président de la
république a une double tâche à définir
enfin clairement devant les français le
premier s'est nommé sa politique
économique et sociale qu'on sache voilà
qu'on sache exactement ce que c'est moi
je l'appelle social-libéral rockstar
gros mot chez les socialistes alors il
faut peut-être un employé à notre tête
il suffit des socialistes peut-être
qu'il suffit dire socialiste est de
donner un autre contenu mais en tout cas
il ya besoin qu'on comprenne exactement
où il va et puis la deuxième chose c'est
aussi qu'ils nous expliquent pour lui je
dirais définitivement jusqu'à la fin du
mandat ce que dira le pacte républicain
c'est ces deux attentes sont extrêmement
forts seul un président de la république
remplissons son rôle peut répondre à ces
deux choses là et c'est très différent
dur lui parti socialiste à vrai dire le
rôle du parti socialiste est presque
encore plus compliqué parce que on n'a
jamais su sous la vème république
à quoi servait exactement le parti
majoritaire c'est très compliqué pas
parti godillot pas non plus partie se
mettant à avoir d autonomie trop forte
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
l'équipe actuelle du parti socialiste a
- encore bien réussi que tous les partis
de majorité après 16 heures
cette équipe alors réaffirmer le cap
parce que le cap il avait été défini il
a été dessinée assez clairement
d'ailleurs tout le monde s'en était
félicité lors de la conférence de presse
du président de la république qu'on
avait d'ailleurs caractérisée de social
libéral social libéral c'est un très bon
aussi on et sociale en économie et
libéral sur les questions de société
c'est très beau mais il est connoté dans
l'histoire des socialistes par le
blairisme ou le nouveau centre de
monsieur schröder et donc évidemment ce
n'est pas facile à porter mais bref
cette orientation a été portée puisqu'on
a dit nous allons faire une politique de
l'offre est pas de la demande on a dit
que pour c'est un grand tournant dans
l'histoire des socialistes et des
sentiments d'allers-retours simon
d'allers-retours oui mais par ce
problème fiscaux et chefs d'entreprise
alors si on peut rester quinze secondes
sur les raisons des allers-retours ses
prévisions tout simple c'est que nous
sommes entre deux abîmes d'un côté la
possibilité d'un mouvement social qui
emporterait la france et de l'autre côté
la possibilité que les marchés
financiers viennent sanctionner la
france et qu'on emprunte à des taux qui
nous pouvions pas supporter donc je
demande toujours s'il ya une marge de
manoeuvre parce qu'en ce moment en ce
moment où elle était nue elle était nue
mais en ce moment françois hollande fait
avancer la france vers une nouvelle
france à petit pas est évidemment c'est
difficile a souligné donc c'est pour
cela qu'il doit tout à la fois
réaffirmer le cap
réaffirmé ses objectifs et surtout comme
le dit notre ami terol être le garant de
l'unité de la république plusieurs
langues et roll
je crois que il faut pas suivre les
commentateurs dans cette espèce de
rouler bouler de catastrophisme le dé
qui pleut c'est bon pour le front
national dès qu'il fait beau c'est
mauvais pour le pauvre françois hollande
sachons raison garder ya une vraie mise
en cause de ce que fait le pouvoir
globalement parce que il a vraiment trop
hésiter trop tergiverser on ne sait plus
où il va la république n'est pas en
danger le système institutionnel
fonctionne extrêmement bien et il
garantit tout de même la stabilité
politique il faut donc que voilà on est
un pouvoir qu'il se reprenne une
opposition qui jouent mieux ce rôle
d'opposition parce qu'au fond elle se
contente d'attiser les braises on ne
voit pas non plus d'autres projets et
voilà je crois que les français
reprendront d'abord ils reprendront goût
à la politique avec les municipales et
les européennes parce qu'ils ont envie
de sanctionner le pouvoir et puis je
pense qu'ensuite on reviendra aux
fondamentaux si le président de la
république veut bien jouer pleinement
son rôle c'est de temps jean christophe
cambadélis que le président parle c'est
bien ça va on l'a cayrol merci beaucoup
d'être intervenu au va continuer le fil
de la semaine avec mercredi l'heure est
à l'union sacrée
christiane taubira à nouveau prise pour
cible cette fois par l'hebdomadaire
minute jean marc ayrault a saisi le
procureur de la république et une
enquête a été ouverte par le parquet
pour injures publiques à caractère
racial thibault le floch hugo leenhardt
ministre une parution comme celle là
mesdames et messieurs les députés ce
n'est pas de l'information
c'est une infraction et cette infraction
appelle sanction si sanction il ya ce
sera à la justice de décider laquelle
alors qu'une enquête préliminaire pour
injure raciale a été ouverte contre
l'hebdomadaire minute mais en attendant
la quasi totalité de la classe politique
a tenu à manifester son soutien à la
garde des sceaux et a condamné les
propos du journal d'extrême droite
franchement s'il faut faire des
poursuites sur minutes il entraîne à ne
plus paraître très franchement je ne
sais pas je ne serai pas le dernier à le
regretter mais à droite certains comme
patrick ollier regrette que cette
affaire occupe l'espace médiatique
vous me parler aujourd'hui de l'union
sacrée contre le racisme vous ne me
parlez pas du matraquage fiscal ne
parlait pas de la dérive économique vous
parlez pas les déficits vont nous parler
de la lutte contre le racisme et là
vraiment c'est de l'empilement politique
voilà ce que je dis certains élus de
droite dénoncent ces comportements tout
en disant qu' un contexte national qui
peut expliquer que etc il faut condamner
sans réserve ce type de comportement
c'est le socle républicain du pacte
républicain qui est en jeu justement
pour protéger ce socle une marche des
républicains sera organisée dans
plusieurs villes le 8 décembre prochain
côté socialiste ce sont les permanences
des députés qui devraient être ouvertes
ce week end à j'ai demandé à tous les
parlementaires socialistes de faire en
sorte que leur permanence soit ce
week-end là les maisons de la république
les maisons qui accueilleront tous les
républicains pour débattre avec eux pour
débattre de la république et ça sera ma
façon de joindre le groupe socialiste
d'initiatives qui auront lieu ce
week-end quelques milliers de personnes
ont déjà annoncé sur internet qu'ils
participeront à cette marche des
républicains réunis derrière un symbole
celui de marianne avec écrit j'ai besoin
de vous un jean christophe cambadélis
l'appel est lancé sur la toile est ce
que vous en serez cette marche des
républiques à ce que votre permanence
sera oui tout à fait il faut en être il
faut qu'il y ait un maximum de
républicains qu'ils fassent bloc parce
que sans que la république aujourd'hui
soient attaqués par des groupes factieux
nous sommes pas dans les années 30 il y
à un climat qui est dommageable au
consensus national sur des sur des
causes qui sont nécessaires au
redressement de la france est encore
puissante face à ce type d'actes
d'agissements
pour cela il faut une volonté et quand
ya pas de volonté quand on est dans le
commentaire simplement
évidemment
on ajoute du brouhaha au bois le front
national à condamner la une deux minutes
est ce que ça veut dire pour autant que
le front national est un parti n'est pas
raciste d un parti d'extrême droite je
les dis je les répéter c'est pas la
première année que je le dis
c'est un parti qui préconise la
préférence nationale la priorité aux
français de souche contre les français
de papier et à partir de là vous ouvrez
la boîte à tout ce qui n'est pas
français qu'est ce qui n'est pas
français c'est pas facile a débuté à
définir et donc elle partir de là vous
avez les dérapages que l'on connaît
alors évidemment ça fait pas beau dans
le décor mais marine le pen par exemple
joue sur l'ambiguïté elle dit c'est
condamnable mais en même temps on peut
comprendre elle reste dans l'entre-deux
et puis vous avez la démonstration
aujourd'hui elle fait le tour des
groupes d'extrême droite en europe pour
constituer un veau au parlement européen
s'il fallait signer la nature de cette
formation politique elle vient d'être
fait par le mouvement même demain de
marine le pen en europe paseo jeudi la
majorité est en difficultés au sénat
au sénat le débat a tourné court le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale a été rejetée et dans
un dernier baroud d'honneur le
gouvernement a demandé un vote bloqué
enfin récit d'une séance très agitée
quand à calmer ce devait être une
journée sans surprise où la droite et
les élus communistes associant vote pour
vider de toute substance le texte de
financement de la sécurité sociale trop
dispendieux pour les uns pas assez
ambitieux pour les autres pourtant à
l'approché du vote final et contre toute
attente le gouvernement demande en vain
de bloquer un coup de tonnerre dans
l'hémicycle le gouvernement demande au
sénat de procéder à une seconde
délibération des articles 8 à 8 9 10 10
bis en clair les sénateurs sont invités
à voter sur le texte du gouvernement et
non sur celui qu'ils ont amendé bronca
dans l'hémicycle immédiatement de
nombreux sénateurs demandent la parole
et ce procédé pour établir le texte tel
que vous le souhaitez je trouve est
absolument méprisant pour le sénat il
est méprisant pour l'ensemble des
sénatrices et des sénateurs ici présents
les groupes politiques sont outrés y
compris sur les bancs communiste où les
attaquer les gars de 7 procédures sont
plein d'amertume que le gouvernement ait
recours à cette à ce déni de démocratie
je dirais même à cette mascarade
personnellement pour essayer d'échapper
à la situation qui a eu lieu suite à la
réforme des retraites
je trouve que c'est grave ça a été dit
et je trouve qu'il y avait d'autre issue
agacé les sénateurs socialistes décident
de défendre l'exécutif et le projet de
loi et son prennent frontalement alors
que les communistes dans cet hémicycle
personne je dis bien personne n'a le
monopole des politiques de bosch c'est
la raison pour laquelle je vous dis
souffrez que nous ayons des désaccords
qui sont des désaccords de fond et pas
simplement des accords de procédure et
que vous n'incarnez par un
décorateur après ces échanges houleux
inhabituelle au sénat attention
redescend d'un cran le résultat du vote
tombe les socialistes votent le texte du
gouvernement et sauve les apparences
mais cela ne suffira pas il est rejeté à
189 voix contre 139 est-ce que vous
reconnaissez qu'il ya quand même un
problème de majorité notamment au sénat
ce que pense que la majorité sera au
rendez vous pour le vote du budget mardi
prochain alors il ya une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale comme à
l'assemblée nationale mais au sénat à
partir du moment où le parti communiste
qui n'est pas membre de la majorité
préventes de majorité présidentielle
mais pas gouvernementale
mais c'est vrai avec la droite important
mais sous les situent pas le parti
socialiste où la majorité de gauche qui
est responsable de la stratégie
politique du parti communiste et de ses
contradictions entre monsieur laurent
monsieur mélenchon qu'ils essaient de
gérer comme ils peuvent donc je nous on
n'y peut pas grand chose c'est pour cela
qu'il fallait réaffirmer au sénat ce qui
était la position de la gauche et de son
gouvernement il a fait son travail bien
sûr évidemment c'est ça gêne un peu hâlé
communisme et nous on n'est pas
responsable de leurs rivaux mardi
prochain à l'assemblée je l'espère je
l'espère je l'espère question la
commission européenne valide le projet
de budget pour la france mais dit il n'y
a pas de marge de manoeuvre possible au
cas de dérapage donc quand même un petit
avertissement c'est un oui mais est-ce
que ça veut dire que on a quand même
quelques éventuels et un homme de
problèmes aux perspectives et l'europe
là nous donne un blanc seing mais avec
quelques réserves
la robe et la commission fait son
travail ou 2 ou donnent l'impression de
faire son travail parce qu'elle n'est
pas neutre elle est sur une idéologie
politique
à l'évidence c'est une majorité
conservatrice et les positions de
monsieur barroso quand on l'entend quand
il vient en france et il parle il parle
comme un libéral d'ailleurs on a inventé
un terme à bruxelles on a peur ça on
appelle ça l'ordo libéralisme c'est à
dire qu'on s'appuie sur les les traités
et en même temps on est totalement
libérale mais il donne acte quand même à
la france du travail qui a été fait
jusqu'à présent et il
développe ce que je disais tout à
l'heure que l'allemagne a des excédents
excessifs
ceci est une rupture de la solidarité
européenne c'est très exactement la
thèse de la france et particulièrement
de françois hollande le président de la
république développé en europe depuis un
bon bout de temps que la formation venue
de deux gosses elle bonne ou mauvaise
nouvelle pour françois hollande mais
c'est une nouvelle qu'il faut intégrer
comme
un élément de la politique européenne
mais nous il faut qu'on continue sur
notre objectif pas bousculé par ce que
dit bruxelles désormais les budgets de
chacun des états membres sont sont
transmis à la commission européenne
jamais le contrôle de tous par tous qui
est ce que dans ce contexte la france
conserve sa souveraineté budgétaire sous
l'oeil de naucelle mais bien sûr
puisqu'on a bien analysé elle qui décide
bruxelles n'a pas la possibilité
de dalles ministre et la france bon mais
à partir du moment où nous nous
réclamons homme de gauche une politique
beaucoup plus solidaire une relance de
la croissance pour cela il faut que nous
soyons contrôler pour que d'autres
puissent être contrôlés et donc nous
avons été contrôlés d'abord nous a dit
que nous allions dans le bon sens très
bien mais aujourd'hui
sans que ça soit une critique sur nos
amis allemands on a indiqué qu' il était
en excédent et excessif ce qui n'était
jamais le cas auparavant on nous disait
quoi qu'est ce que nous disaient les
comédiens les commentateurs il nous
disait regardez l'allemagne ils sont
quand même extraordinairement fort
besoin d roubaix c'est donc du coup
c'est une bonne nouvelle
puisqu'ils l'ont pas demandé de baisser
ils ont demandé excusez moi qu'il y ait
une relance interne dans en allemagne
c'est à dire que les salaires puissent
augmenter
bon ben voilà donc c'est sûr je dirais
quelque part que c'est une revendication
de gauche c'est la revendication du spd
dans les négociations en ce moment avec
la cd ou lassés des sous alors quitté
provisoirement l'europe on vient en
france avec la réforme des rythmes
scolaires qui suscite toujours autant de
colère des enseignants du primaire ont
manifesté cette semaine aux côtés de
parents d'élèves un collectif de 55
maire ump ou sans étiquette a aussi
prévenu qu'il n'appliquerait pas la
réforme en l'état à la rentrée 2014
écoutez cet échange musclé dans
l'hémicycle avec le ministre de
l'éducation a sont payants comme de
nombreux maires je refuse d'appliquer
votre réforme en 2014 alors que d'autres
qui avaient cru et 2013 fort marche
arrière
monsieur peillon dit que nous sommes des
délinquants si vite souvenez-vous des
mots de bertrand de la noue et refusant
d'appliquer la loi en 2008 accueillir
les enfants dans une école c'est sérieux
et ne peut être fait sans personnel
qualifié disait-il je suis je vous le
confesse un peu troublé d'entendre de
cet hémicycle un député de la
souveraineté nationale chargé de voter
la loi déclaration publique et
solennelle de la volonté générale sur un
objet d'intérêt commun déclaré qu'il
n'appliquera pas les votes de la loire
s
un exemple que vous donnez est ce cela
dans le pays a besoin ici nous devons
respecter la démocratie la démocratie
c'est aussi la loi la loi vous devez la
respecter comme tout le monde
alors la droite et notamment jean
françois copé dit que le gouvernement
n'a pas le droit d'imposer une
compétence nouvelle à une municipalité
sans lui transférer les fonds
correspondant qu'est-ce que vous
vraiment on a écouté tout ça sous de
polémiques secondaire au ce que je
remarque c'est que la droite l'a pas le
courage de défendre les positions qui
étaient les siennes quand elle était au
pouvoir
c'est valable sur la question des
rythmes scolaires comme c'est valable
sur l'écotaxe à chaque fois parce qu'il
ya des mouvements on s'adapte à ces
mouvements épars jura par rapport à ses
propres propositions non cadrée je pense
qu'il ya deux choses il ya deux choses
différentes derrière il y a deux et je
vous demande de revenir en arrière quand
je reviens pas en arrière on n'est figé
quand on revient en arrière on fait de
l'agglo disent donc il faut garder
encore une fois raison donc il faut
distinguer deux choses il peut y avoir
ici vous là des problèmes d'adaptation
de la réforme quand la réforme est votée
on a vot comment se fait-il que des
députés de droite qui sont sans arrêt à
faire la leçon et indiqué qu'aujourd'hui
on ne respecte pas la loi par exemple
dans les banlieues et ils ont pas
toujours tort oui aujourd'hui donne
l'exemple donne l'exemple de ne pas la
respecter devant la représentation
nationale
écoutez moi je crois que ça pose un
problème plutôt du côté de la droite que
du côté de la caisse qui peut pas aussi
vous pouvez éventuellement vous poser un
problème c'est que les profs dans la rue
c'est difficile à encaisser quand même
pour la noce c'est là où je distinguais
d'une d'une manipulation politique de
problèmes d'application de la loi bon là
il peut y avoir ici ou là mécontentement
ça existe il faut le prendre en compte
et je crois que le ministre dialogue et
les municipalités dialogue avec les
enseignants pour essayer de surmonter
ces difficultés qui sont quand même pas
immense qu'il faut quand même faire
revenir à la table rediscuter vaut
prévoir un éventuel aménagement de série
des volets duriez voilà les socialistes
à chaque fois qu'il ya un problème recul
et bien non recule pas on peut bien dire
t on veut bien aménagé mais la loi sera
appliquée
plus revient pas en arrière sur la tva
vous savez très bien qu'elle est gagé
pour free lance et le cic e et le cic
lasser les membres moteur de la
tentation thème la très précis vous
voulez vous que l'on bouge sur ce thème
là vous avez bougé sur sa bouche et
vous voyez
on vaccine de défendre une position
puisque de toute façon quelle que soit
la position que l'on prend elle sera
critique et c'est ce que je dis à mes
collègues donc ne vous fatiguez pas
faut assumer être dans le juste et au
bout il y aura le redressement de la
france et selah sue conjure a parlé du
national tout à l'heure en cette fin de
semaine le parti de marine le pen se met
en ordre de bataille pour l'élection
municipale plus de 600 têtes de listes à
travers la france le détail avec cajas
car à moins de six mois des élections
municipales le fn lance officiellement
ce week-end sa campagne au siège du
parti une équipe dédiée la préparation
du scrutin est déjà à pied d'oeuvre
depuis plusieurs mois et le parti de
marine le pen a bien compris qu'il ne
pouvait plus uniquement compter sur les
présidentielles pour renforcer son
implantation locale c'est la première
fois qu'il jette autant de forces dans
la bataille des municipales
on sait très inquiet que l'est du pays
sont aux présidentielles initiative
selon le csa maintenant notre ambition
c'est aussi effectivement d'être prêts
professionnels ont créé pour toutes les
élections
stratégiquement le front national entend
jouer sur plusieurs tableaux et espère
pouvoir compter dans des communes de
toutes tailles mais à trop trois grands
enjeux la ruralité dans laquelle nous
sommes très forte nous permettra
d'envoyer beaucoup de représentants dans
les conseils municipaux des petits
villages et d'avoir des mères aussi il
ya des villes moyennes vous citez
forbach penser à carpentras on peut se
penser à tarascon hénin-beaumont bien
sûr et d'autres beaucaire et c'est sur
lesquels il ya les vraies chances de
l'emporter vraiment moi à forbach je
pense que j'ai une chance sérieuse
d'être mère en mars prochain et puis il
ya les grandes villes les grandes villes
le fn y dépêche ses principaux cadres
florian philippot à forbach louis aliot
à perpignan steeve briois hénin beaumont
robert ménard à béziers ou encore
stéphane ravier à marseille des choix
d'investiture qui ne doivent rien au
hasard à part du lion vous avez
quelqu'un du front national qui a déjà
une notoriété et qui est candidat ça
veut dire qu'il ya une chance de faire
un beau score sinon il n'envoie pas le
front national a des moyens de campagne
très limités et donc dès qu'il ya un
coup à jouer il envoie un poids lourds
où il envoie quelqu'un qui s'appelle le
pen aujourd'hui le fn revendique plus de
600 listes constituées pour mars 2014 en
2008 le parti n'avait réussi à présenter
que 80 listes estampillées fn des
candidats presque partout en france
c'est quoi ou c'est qui votre arme au
titre national pas partout en france
presque partout je n'aurais même pas
presque partout en france presque 700 à
1 700 sur plus de 4000 c'est pas tout à
fait partout mais c'est très important
c'est très important parce que je ne
pense pas qu'ils le front national
remportera des villes ou très peu je
pense qu'ils vont rentrer dans tous les
conseils municipaux et ça va changer la
nature des conseils municipaux depuis
très longtemps des conseils municipaux
traiter des questions municipales et
nous avions plus de débats avaient vu
dans l'ancien temps de débat de
politique nationale là le front national
va poser ses thèmes c'est à dire la
priorité nationale la préférence
nationale dans la gestion de chacune des
villes ils veulent faire quelque chose
au niveau municipal et non pas au niveau
national donc c'est au niveau municipal
qui reprendront leurs problématiques
nationales mais vous allez avoir donc à
partir de là des conflits politiques qui
vont ressurgir dans les conseils
municipaux vous aurez par exemple un
responsable du front national qui dira
que à la cantine il n'est pas normal
qu'une ans et embaucher des gens qui ne
sont pas de souche et qui mettront
campagne là dessus ça va changer
beaucoup je le dis à mes camarades et
mes amis et à tous les démocrates savent
abou changer beaucoup la gestion de vos
villes vous allez vous trouver confronté
à une confrontation frontale pourquoi
via parce que nous sommes rentrés dans
un trip artistes dont l'un des partis
est un parti d'extrême droite et ça va
être ça la donne jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle
et comme ils ont l'élection
présidentielle en tête les leaders du
front national vous pensez bien que ils
vont utiliser
les municipales comme tremplin pour
mener leurs campagnes d'e nationaliser
l'enjeu pour vous non le but n'est pas
nationaliser l'enjeu le but est de
mobiliser les abstentionnistes parce
qu'ils se le front national sera
d'autant plus haut qu'il y aura de
l'abstention aussi une percée c'est ça
qui est nouveau au niveau européen
puisque marine le pen tente de fédérer
les partis d'extrême droite euros
critiques voire hors forme au niveau
européen comment vous expliquer cette
montée de cette extrême europe sur le
vieux continent eh bien il ya deux
raisons la raison de fond qui est
l'interrogation de la vieille europe par
rapport à son identité et à partir de là
la résurgence de mouvement et 8
identitaire nationaliste voire
régionaliste et deuxièmement la
politique d'austérité menée par les
gouvernements de droite majoritaire en
europe à l'initiative de la cdo depuis
maintenant plus de dix ans est donc
sacré la situation telle qu'on la
connaît thiva de aube dorée qui est un
mouvement
palais aux nazis totalement nazis à
marine le pen qui essayent de camoufler
sa véritable sa véritable nature oui
mais vous verrez que le bloc des
populistes lors des élections
européennes s'il n'y prend pas garde le
bloc des populistes sera suffisamment
important pour perturber le parlement
qui va conquérir ses droits puisqu'on
pourra élire le président à la halle à
la commission sera tout l'enjeu des
élections européennes
alors jean christophe cambadélis on va
ouvrir une page une séquence politique
fiction toujours sous le signe du doute
quand les doutes du couple font écho aux
doutes politique c'est le thème d'un
film sorti cette semaine il est signé de
la réalisatrice yamina lilas kumar
comédie dramatique chronique du
sentiment politique avant goût avec
simon barbarie
un couple un politologue est une
historienne qui face à un autre un
journaliste comédienne entre la primaire
socialiste de 2007 et la présidentielle
de 2012 les discussions de ces quatre à
l'iml intime et le commentaire
d'actualité politique jusqu'à se
confondre avec un point d'ancrage
croyez-vous qu'on peut vivre pendant 10
ans auprès de quelqu'un et ne pas le
connaître quand tu me regardes
tu trouves ça y ressemble à un canton
suisse
au fil d'une neutralité absolue regard
clair et franc toi tu es le roi la
discimination doute c'est le titre du
long métrage de gamine il est là kumar
en selle cette semaine incarnée par des
échanges d'intellectuels parisien le
film retrace une période de désarroi
pour la gauche française avec la défaite
de ségolène royal à la présidentielle ou
encore la mise en examen de dominique
strauss kahn c'est bien qu'ils aient pu
raconter sa vérité à laquelle choisir la
vérité c'est qu'il a failli planter
toute la gauche le libertin assumer
reconnaît la faute morale et les bras
m'en tombent si le film se veut être à
mi chemin entre documentaire et fiction
la rhétorique bien trop parfaite des
personnages place ce premier long
métrage dans une irréalité télégénique
reste à savoir si le grand public sera
au rendez vous le doute est permis
et oui vous l'avez reconnu christophe
barbier avec vous êtes acteur il veut
jouer aussi votre rôle directeur de la
rédaction du journal l'express merci de
venir aux tirs dont vous parler un peu
de ce film vous jouez donc votre propre
rôle non non non je lui ai d'abord je
joue chris bell et un sondeur donc déjà
on est dans un rapport la politique
différent politologues sondeurs
insondable le sondeur yvan des études il
vend du conseil donc il a un rapport au
politique qui n'est pas celui de
l'éditorialiste ou du journaliste
politique et puis je suis surtout là
pour faire le sparring partner avec les
autres personnages notamment celui qui
incarne benjamin biolay qui est un
journaliste alors lui complètement
engagé à gauche complètement engagé aux
côtés de dominique strauss kahn et qui
vit donc cette période 2006 2012 avec
évidemment les chocs qu'on a tous vécu
en 2011 2012 et puis cette période là
jean christophe ce qu'il en est question
dans le film le doute et poke et en grec
l'époque et le doc du monde de l'époque
et liens douteux oui c'est des choses
qui existent du point de vue de ce que
peut faire ce que doit faire comment
faire au niveau de la gauche
évidemment nous avons quitté les années
70 et les années 80 où il y avait là des
certitudes qui ont été érodées par la
réalité et la dureté des temps ça ça
existe mais il n'y a pas de doute sur
les principes il n'y a pas de doute sur
les principes mêmes de la gauche sur les
principes et valeurs non sur l'identité
de la gauche il ya un doute frotter
justement l'expérience du pouvoir dans
ces années 80 90 et puis il ya un doute
sur l'identité de la gauche sur son
enracinement et les personnages du film
portait ça puisque judith l'art ali rao
qui joue mon épouse est une historienne
et elle pense que c'est au moment de
vichy que secret que ce retrait
l'identité française et que la gauche
évidemment ne peut pas se tromper de
caen et doit revenir toujours à cette
période là pour refonder son identité le
sondeur que je jouais beaucoup plus
pragmatique la gauche ne doit être
efficace donc quand elle était au
gouvernement elle doit trouver les
solutions qui marchent comme disait tony
blair donc il est beaucoup plus sur ce
cynisme là et benjamin biolay essaye de
de résumer les de gauche celle que
strauss kahn incarne s il ya une
compatibilité avec l'univers économique
mondialisé et celle que avec françois
mitterrand avec lionel jospin d'autres
ont voulu garder dans une certaine forme
de lyrisme
la gauche pragmatique ou la gauche qui
se cherche encore elle est
obligatoirement pragmatique parce que
les sous contrainte elle n'a pas choisi
le terrain et le moment où elle est
arrivée elles sont contraintes des
déficits publics et les sous contrainte
de notre perte de du point de vue
industriel et sous contrainte de lever
l'interrogation d'identité française et
les sous contrainte européenne de la
mondialisation j'en passe et des
meilleures idées donc elle est
obligatoirement pragmatique mais j'avais
essayé dans un ouvrage la troisième
gauche de lui donner une cohérence et de
dd de surmonter cette contradiction
entre
disons une gauche d'adaptation et une
gauche de compétition réaliste
que le propos du film c'est ça c'est la
recherche la chasse permanente désespéré
à cette troisième gauche comment trouver
cette fameuse troisième gauche qui
permet de ne pas renier ce qui a été la
gauche idéaliste de ne pas tomber dans
la gauche protestataire stériles comme
jean luc mélenchon l'incarnent
aujourd'hui est de trouver une gauche
moderne qui intègre l'écologie qui
intègre quand même des notions de
libéralisme et de pragmatisme
économistes pas simple alors tant le
film on passe des convictions intimes d1
aux interrogations politiques des autres
on passe tu es documentaire à la fiction
comment vous définirez ce film est ce
que c'est une comédie politique est ce
que c'est une fiction basée sur des
faits réels comment vous pouvez définir
c'est totalement une fiction c'est
vraiment un film écrit et très très le
sujet le disait très bien il ya une
rhétorique extrêmement forte et
extrêmement dense pas tout à fait
naturelle qui vient se plaquer comme le
10e succès sur un univers bobos et cette
gauche bobo elle est à la fois très
antipathique elle est d'ailleurs très
décrié depuis les salons de
saint-germain-des-prés comment peut-on
parler de la gauche et en même temps la
gauche a toujours été pensé la gauche a
toujours été porté par ce qu'on appelle
les élites et vous en parliez tout à
l'heure il ya ces deux coupures donc
voilà le propos du film comment on peut
rallumer la mèche rallumer la flamme de
cette gauche qui est censé inventer la
gauche dans ses thèmes danser dans ses
idéaux pour après aller parler aux
électeurs aux électeurs tentés par
l'abstentionnisme aux électeurs partis
vers les extrêmes qu'il est si difficile
de récupérer allumé la flamme en
question
le film
je n'en doute pas
à ses traits à cette réunion c'est c'est
plus facile de le faire je le confesse
dans l'opposition que au
gouvernement mais je crois je crois je
suis persuadé qu'il faut le faire c'est
un travail auxquelles devrait s'attacher
le parti socialiste c'est insensé ça me
semble essentiel c'est à pamiers pour
conclure est ce que vous imaginez la
politique comme l'avenir du cinéma
français a je pense que la politique va
être de plus importante au sein du
cinéma français on le voit on le voit
d'ailleurs on l'a vu avec l'exercice de
l'état on l'a vu avec la conquête et la
politique
et européens mais pas la politique
historique parce qu'on a tous fait et vu
des docu fiction sur le passé non la
politique récente voir la politique en
train de se faire sur le ferry nos aussi
en est un exemple comme matière au
cinéma mais le cinéma va être aussi le
salut de la politique parce que les
jeunes militants c'est par le cinéma
c'est par la fiction sépare l'artistique
qu'on va les ramener au coeur de au
coeur de la politique non seulement pour
voter mais pour aussi à prendre la
succession de l'été glorieuses aînées le
doute actuellement donc stocks
américains est ce parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup des 12
à notre émission katia on se retrouve là
son prochain très beau site de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires merci de votre fidélité
ouah